[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno creo que para cerrar de una manera
algo diferente hablaré en español y
quiero saber si todos me eventos me
entienden pues se ven genial me encanta
ese teatro porque es pequeño todo el
mundo ve sin importar dónde esté sentado
no es así en todos de hecho voy mucho al
teatro mayor el norte de la ciudad y
creía que era así hasta que cumple las
boletas de mitad de precio y entendí por
qué eran de mitad de precio
pero creo que el mayor problema en los
tratos de bogotá acerca de esto es el
teatro colon es el teatro típico de la
ciudad que tuvo la ópera de la ciudad
durante mucho tiempo y queda en el
centro de la ciudad a tan sólo unas
cuadras del palacio nariño y la última
vez que fui fui con mi novia porque nos
invitaban a una ceremonia a un diván
habla el presidente santos y timochenko
acerca de lo que ocurrió en el último
año desde que se firmó el acuerdo final
para la terminación del conflicto entre
las farc
y el estado
y al llegar y visitar los diferentes
puestos y cuáles funcionaban y cuáles no
en cuáles se había y cuáles no me acordé
de la última es anterior a esa en la que
ves al teatro colón que fue el 2 de
octubre hemos comprado a asientos en las
galerías para el sujeto 2 x 4 y en mi
lógica estaba que la mejor manera de
celebrar la victoria del sí en el
plebiscito iba a ser escuchar al sujeto
2004 porque pues el bien de sudáfrica de
la segregación tienen las necesidades de
nelson mandela
y llegamos el intermedio
y el definitivo
con diferencia y 40.000 votos 97 por
ciento de los votos escrutados gane el
no y el país entero entorno
incertidumbre no sabemos qué va a pasar
no fue inmediato en cuestión de los
siguientes días en conversaciones con
amigos y con profesores note que ya no
podemos dejar la suerte del país en
manos de un grupo limitado de personas
en la ciudad de la habana y que tenemos
que empezar a movilizarnos porque
teníamos una convicción
ahora no les puedo decir si estoy en lo
correcto o no
tengo la convicción de lo que soy pero
no lo podría escribir en piedra
pero si después decir que en el último
año largo año y seis meses he aprendido
una que otra cosa acerca de cambiar el
mundo
tiene que quiere que puede cambiar el
ok pocas manos la gente que no levantó
la mano debería prestarle particular
atención a esto ahora entiendo que la
mayoría que no tienen el poder de un
gobernante un país no tienen los
recursos que ongs internacionales o
cooperación internacional tienen para
lograr cambios profundos pero
el cambio en nuestra sociedad empieza en
los cambios en los núcleos más pequeños
es decir cambiar el mundo comienza en
cambiar la familia en cambiar la
comunidad y así cambiado la ciudad
cambiamos el país y cambiamos el mundo
la pregunta es qué se requiere para eso
de nuevo no puedes creer en piedra pero
de mi experiencia e notado que hay tres
actitudes que son claves para poder
cambiar el mundo
el inconformismo creo que
la gran mayoría si no todas las personas
acá sigo con mis suposiciones
suelen conformen cerca la manera en que
funciona el mundo
de otra manera no habría ningún punto en
escuchar charlas y buscar conocer otras
ideas
pero es muy fácil pegarse ante las
inconformidades cuando uno tiene
privilegios
nos dividimos entre nosotros y ellos
nosotros porque no nos vemos
dificultades en las inequidades ya veces
nos vemos profundamente beneficiados de
las inequidades no podemos ver que ellos
lejanos
están sufriendo están viviendo mal
dicen que el fascismo se quita leyendo y
el racismo viajando y ese es el primer
tema para mantener el inconformismo
conocer leer ir a comunidades lejanas ir
a los barrios marginados de una ciudad
ir a las zonas rurales de un país
hablar con la gente entender que sufren
porque sufren y qué se puede hacer por
ellos
perfecto a veces hay poderes superiores
que no permiten cambios profundos pero
lograr que una comunidad de mujeres como
una queda en la ciudad de bogotá tenga
una huerta propia que les dé ingresos a
ellas para que no tengan que depender de
sus maridos
es un cambio profundo en sus vidas y de
esa manera un cambio frontal o social
de esa misma manera construir un parque
para que los niños de una vereda
en un departamento de nuestro país tengo
un lugar seguro donde jugar
es asegurar que esa vereda no va a tener
niños dando vueltas y teniendo contacto
con actividad ilegal conociendo a la
otra persona tenemos la posibilidad de
entender realmente quiénes requiere el
cambio y qué podemos hacer para
conseguirlo
pero
particularidades quien no levantaban la
mano
no puedo solucionar a veces
efectivamente no tenemos las
herramientas para lograr los cambios
profundos que se requiere a veces
tenemos un poder limitado una influencia
limitada pero como decía antes acciones
pequeñas hacen diferencias grandes
entonces el hecho de que no nos va a
solucionar en su totalidad o en la
situación no significa que uno no tenga
la responsabilidad de tomar el cambio de
hacer lo posible de tratar ayudar
ya veces no es fácil
pienso una sociedad que es conformista
náusea que prefiere mantener el status
quo
se requiere una gran valentía para poder
lograr cambios en esta sociedad y eso
tiene muchísimas caras
creo que la cara más famosa en este
momento de este cambio en la sociedad es
mala de salsa y premio nobel de paz
es realmente un ejemplo
pero por qué
porque su valentía no radicó en la
violencia tendremos continuamente al
vincular la valentía con los soldados
con la guerra con la destrucción la
valentía de ella recurre a la
resistencia ante la violencia
maneras haustein cuando llegan los
talibanes a disparar le preguntan quién
es mala la responde yo soy mala y aún
después de ser víctima de la violencia
más terrible por su activismo por querer
que las mujeres en el valle de swat en
pakistán pudieran tener su educación
continúo trabajando y esto lleva a que
hoy a pesar de que sea el exilio en el
reino unido tenga un poder influyente
muy importante
puede primar a la fondo que logra darle
educación a miles de mujeres arroyos del
mundo
pero más el caracas stalin el palacios
en bojayá en 2003 una masacre que mató a
cerca de 100 personas en el catedral de
ohio y como es común de la manera que
funciona el conflicto nuestro país
quienes estaban sobrevivientes de esta
masa que ser obligados a movilizarse por
el río atrato que estaba completamente
rodeados de diferentes actores armados
en el palacios
tiene una resistencia particular
y es una resistencia en lo básico
él dice somos la sociedad civil queremos
que nos respeten la vida
la valentía no está necesariamente en
los grandes actos de heroísmo frente a
las grandes atrocidades la valentía está
en temas simples como
pero no esos en la manera en que
compartimos ideas con familiares y
amigos que a veces no piensan lo mismo y
entra en debates constructivos sin tener
miedo de que la gente piense diferente o
que nos derroten por medio argumentos la
valentía está en no tenerle miedo al
poder y a veces sabes estar en
desacuerdo con el poder
la valentía está en la convicción en
creer que es posible hacer un cambio y
estar definido a qué se hace todo lo
posible hasta el final
pero dónde queda el final
donde queda la valentía si no hay
acciones reales que pueden hacer cambio
por eso creo que la creatividad es un
punto esencial si no quiere transformar
el mundo
y la creatividad
básicamente es pensar afuera la caja y
utilizar las herramientas que hay en
este momento para poder alcanzar cambios
por ejemplo las redes sociales ahora las
redes sociales en el último año largo
también
han sido objeto de grandes maltratos
se ha convertido en la mejor manera de
fundir fake news
y otros tipos de propaganda que lo que
buscan es confundir a la gente pero es
una manera las redes sociales han sido
una herramienta muy efectiva para
movimientos como time shop imitó en los
eeuu como la primavera árabe donde se
reunieron personas de todo el continente
para lograr un cambio que todos querían
en 2011
ahora para que su prensa de las redes
sociales para todo se pueden usar para
organizar y movilizar gente en
movilizaciones que pueden ser
presenciales marchas de miles o millones
de personas o virtuales hashtags
campañas publicitarias que la gente
comparte imágenes pueden ser utilizadas
para mover información para que la gente
se eduque para proveer a la gente
información que de otra manera no
tendrían
puede ser utilizada para lograr
compartir ideas y hacer debates
profundos que nos hagan entender mejor
la situación molestando el mundo y que
soluciones necesarias pero esto me lleva
a otro punto que requiere pensar fue la
caja
nadie va a cambiar el mundo solo eso no
ha pasado una sola vez la bandera tenía
al congreso nacional africano
gandhi y martin luther king junior
tenían sus movimientos de derechos
civiles hasta málaga en el movimiento
internacional que la apoyaba y por eso
logra ser potente
tenemos que aprender a trabajar en grupo
a ser los de los individualismos y de
los egos que a veces ocurren cuando hay
posibilidades de poder puede aparecer
necesitamos entender que el mejor cambio
en el mundo sería logrado sin 8 mil
millones de personas se decían una gente
ahora naturalmente eso es imposible pero
siguiendo esa lógica entre más personas
lo queremos organizar hay aquello que
creemos necesario entre más personas
logremos unir en esfuerzos más potentes
será el cambio que vamos a lograr entre
más participativas en las dinámicas más
aseguramos que realmente los cambios
impacten generaciones enteras y no sólo
lo que pueda hacer una persona u otra
nos dicen mucho que somos el futuro del
mundo
pero realmente en los últimos años es
tener la ilusión esa frase
porque esa frase conlleva una cosa y es
que nos toca esperar
ustedes son el futuro del mundo así que
esperen a que terminemos dañar el mundo
para que se lo vamos a entregar a
ustedes y se lo hacemos más
en este momento tenemos que hacer la
pregunta como generación que le queremos
entregar a nuestros hijos
cómo lo vamos a hacer cuánto tiempo
tenemos 60 años es suficiente
bien lo dijo el gran poeta argentino
fito páez no será tan fácil ya sé qué
pasa
no será tan simple como pensaba
como abrir el pecho y sacar el alma
una cuchillada del amor
dijo que todo está perdido
yo vengo a ofrecer mi corazón
cambiemos las familias cambiemos las
comunidades cambiemos las ciudades
cambiemos los países cambiamos el mundo
desde ya que tenemos dos opciones o
cambiar el mundo hoy o dentro de 20 años
explicar a nuestros hijos por qué no lo
hicimos muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]